this is the eighth generation Fiesta
which Ford hopes will continue the super
mini success story over 17 million
fiestas have been produced and sold in
more than 80 countries today our expert
Michel Samaha is going to test drive the
Fiesta ST line art of Ford sports
technologies range Michelle says the new
Fiesta promises lots of individuality by
mid 2018 there should be seven different
variants on the market with a choice of
25 equipment packages on top at the
front the Fiesta features a large wide
radiator grille as well as static
turning lights the sight rocker panels
are painted the same color as the rest
of the car what's also striking in this
sporty version there's just one exhaust
pipe at the back
with the Fiesta these 5x2 spoke alloy
wheels are exclusive to the esti line
version
Michelle says sty models are more
sportively equipped variants and they're
very popular with buyers around 12% of
all the cars Ford sells are ordered as
st line versions along with yes to six
other Ford models now come with an ST
line option our test car is fitted with
a 1 liter EcoBoost engine which
generates 103 kilowatts of power it
propels the car from 0 to 100 kilometres
an hour and 9 seconds keep the pedal to
the metal and the Fiesta can reach a top
speed of 202 kilometers an hour
[Music]
Michelle says the st line models don't
really cater to those looking for a true
sports car they're more for folks
wanting a dynamic and sporty looking car
that's not a gas guzzler as many sports
cars tend to be
[Music]
inside the changes are clearly visible
the red trim sports seats three-spoke
leather padded steering wheel and sleek
center console give this Vista a sporty
ER look the infotainment system has also
been modernized and now boasts voice
control and phone mirroring
functionality but the esti line offers
more than cosmetic improvements cargo
volume has been increased by a few
litres at least when the car seats are
folded down so that cars more practical
to Michelle says the Fiesta ST line is a
good everyday car and fun to drive
though she finds the steering too soft
and the Ford Fiesta comes pretty much
what do you expect to pay for a small
car Michelle says the base price for a
Ford Fiesta is just under 13,000 euros
whereas the esti line starts at
seventeen thousand eight hundred that's
almost five thousand euros more and
she's not sure the esti lines equipped
but it's worth that much to her buyers
must decide whether the st lines looks
and added features are worth the money
but there's no denying this Fiesta cuts
a good figure whether in city traffic or
on the highway
you